ça c'était mon as garé fréquentent le
refuge des jeunes de montréal un
organisme qui vient en aide aux hommes
de 17 à 25 ans en tant que personnes
trans on lui demande de dormir seul dans
le salon et prendre sa douche avant tout
le monde sait que je me suis ramassé
dans la rue l'est qui a deux en est sûr
c'était comme la première fois que je
t'aide à lui en tant que ma transition
c'est d'absence parce que je suis déjà
été mariée à marc pigeon c'est ce comme
du bop des filles voulaient plus me
prendre parce que m'éclate été changé
légalement tout ce petit bond 10 côté
des gosses qui a désorganisé jeu la plus
penser parce que c'est parce que je suis
pas opérer hockey au canada les seuls
refuges qui s'adressent spécifiquement
personnes trans se trouve à toronto
pourtant les besoins sont réels selon
plan d'action montréalais en itinérance
2018 2020 11% des sans abri de la
métropole sont des personnes lgbt q mais
il n'existe aucune statistique qui
dénombre les personnes trans intervenant
à la mission audry charlie savignac
milite pour plus de services adaptés aux
besoins de cette communauté ont des
lieux et des locaux qu'on peut
difficilement modifiés pour correspondre
aux besoins des personnes trans ce qui
nous manque en fait c'est un refuge
spécifiquement trans pour la protection
de ces personnes là mais pour créer un
sentiment de communauté aussi puis pour
décharger les organismes qui doivent
répondre alors qu' intel hostile pour la
deuxième année en période hivernale
l'ancien hôpital royal victoria se
transforme en refuge d'urgence gérés par
la mission bon accueil même si le
service est temporaire il s'agit du plus
inclusif à montréal ici les personnes
trans ont droit des chambres
individuelles pour soi question ça c'est
pour tout le monde pour tout le monde
acquittement le but c'est pas de savoir
restez pas là vraiment
ces cahiers une place que sochaux sa
part d'agents l'extérieur froid ok
c'était pas un ace pour les gens ont
pour toi n'importe qui peut dans
quelques mois gary orr a dépassé l'âge
limite pour avoir accès au refuge des
jeunes tant bien que mal il multiplie
aujourd'hui les démarches pour se
trouver un appartement gens comment ça
va ça va ouais tu as peur d'avoir un
appart le poste
oui c'est rohff xp mode saas qui me
rappelle chez mon poste j'ai vraiment
essayé de la joindre mon chèque c'est ça
ouais c'est quoi je le trouve à 25 ans
west ham à 27 en janvier donc le tortul
droite est techniquement de venir ici ça
toi ça te stresse venir un nouveau
refuge adapté aux personnes autochtones
a ouvert ses portes au mois de novembre
à montréal en 2020 un programme pour
alcooliques chroniques devraient voir le
jour
s'il est inhérent ce à plusieurs visages
tranquillement les services s'adapte à
la réalité de plus en plus complexes des
sans abri
[Musique]